Okay so we have seen that there is a problem when multiple instructions execute
in the same cycle. And the problem occurs because we need to
read registers before the previous instructions have written them. Because those
previous instructions now execute at the same time as our instruction.
And then we can see that problem really occurs in the execute stage because we
are just operating on wrong value. So let's see in the execute stage if
forwarding can help us with this. If you remember your pipelining.
What forwarding does is it feeds the value from the previous instruction to
the subsequent instructions because those values have actually been written to
register. So let's see if that helps. If you remember,
we had our instructions and now we are just going to look at the execute stage,
and we are going to have our instruction just be I1, I2, I3, I4 and
I5, and remember that there was a dependence from I1 to I2. So
now what would happen is, we execute I1 at some point, and
in the same cycle we execute I2. So the problem with forwarding is
that it would be able to feed this value to the instruction in the next cycle.
But not to an instruction in the same cycle. Cause basically if you look at
the timeline for the cycle. This is the kind of beginning of the execute stage.
This is the end of the execute stage. In here somewhere,
we are kind of taking two values, operating on them, producing the result.
This result is available kind of here, at the end of the cycle.
Meanwhile, the other instruction is taking its values during the subtraction,
producing a result. And this is where forwarding can provide this value.
If forwarding worked, it would have to provide the value here, and
any arrow that goes backward here means basically time travel. So pretty much
you would produce a result and, you know, one cycle send it back in time one
nanosecond earlier, so that it can be used here which is of course impossible.
So we cannot do that. What we will do is not execute this instruction here.
We will have to stall meaning this instruction has to be delayed it just cannot
execute in this cycle. It will execute in the next cycle. If I3,
I4 and I5 don't have any dependencies with I1, they can still execute you
know they have read the register values they're going to be able to execute. So
now what we have is really. We spent two cycles executing five instructions,
okay? So if we ignore the filling of the pipeline and so on,
basically what we have now is the CPI is equal to two over five in this case,
which is approximately 0.4. Actually, it is 0.4. So what we have is a CPI of,
you know, instead of it being 0.2 for these five instructions, it would be 0.4.
If we have a lot of instructions, there will be a lot of these dependencies. So
we will actually have to spend, you know, we will have a CPI that is not zero,
even if we had an infinite number of execution units.